I was at the wedding and I was one of
the few people who was taking photos and
and they said oh where are you gonna get
them developed I said it's fine I got
this little spot and it's it's so good
and then they sent an email or the
Dropbox to these photos to the wrong
person
Liam Hemsworth and Miley Cyrus managed
to keep their wedding on the DL but tons
of intimate pics from their big day
almost went public
thanks to Liam's big brother Chris
that's right on Wednesday Chris
Hemsworth appeared on ITV this morning
in Britain and when he was asked about
the December nuptials the a major star
revealed he had a film camera with him
that day snapped a bunch of pigs and
they nearly leaked when the place where
he had them developed in Australia
accidentally sent them to someone else
let's go put it up on your Instagram and
said hi Chris I've got your photos and
someone then told me and I just ended up
getting ahold of an app but you know I
got a phone number a contact and called
her up and and she couldn't have been
gone there and said don't worry I'm not
gonna do anything with them and they're
sigh oh my god can you imagine getting
an email that's just like loaded with
Hemsworth family pics that girl
seriously won the lottery yeah that
sounds like a really good day now that
lucky recipient was 21 year-old Elvira
Nordstrom after the photo Center made
the epic mix-up she posted this to her
Instagram stories okay so I left my film
role at this place environs to be
developed and they sent me the wrong
photos but hold the [ __ ] up it's not
just anyone's photos it's key Chris
Hemsworth's photos from Liam's and
Miley's secret wedding she then tagged
Kristen opposed to let him know she had
the 216 wedding pics oh that's a lot and
I am living for Elvira space in that
story she's like I mean she's all of us
right anyway Chris responded to her
message writing thank you very much for
not posting our family photos beyond
appreciative for your help so they're
really lucky that it ended up in her
hands because I don't think anyone else
would have been that nice and I bet the
pay day for photos like that would have
been huge so honestly she kind of just
restored my faith in humanity a little
bit so thank you I'll Byron Nordstrom
right shout-out to her yeah of course
only a handful
photos where Miley and Liam's wedding
have been shared on social media but
they did confirm their new official
status as man and wife with these pics
from their I Do's on Instagram et was
with Liam after he tied the knot and he
couldn't help but gush over his leading
lady last thing my gift to you it is a
wedding gift I'm a you know take open it
up see what it is it's cozy it's for
when you're watching drag race with
Miley who are these people this is oh
it's me it's me my wife that's great to
be wife husband and wife it's the best
it's the best you know I feel so lucky
to be with someone like her and yeah
very very very lucky on Valentine's Day
Miley shared a bunch of pics from their
wedding including this sweet shot with
the caption thank you for always bending
down to hug me I promise I will always
meet you in the middle on my tippy toes
I love you Valentine I mean these two
are seriously the cutest who captures
their photo bed like that's like swoon
worthy dippy of course we'll keep you
updated on all things Miley and Liam so
be sure to keep it locked to et until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens and I'm
Courtney tezo bye for now guys
[Music]